[تصفيق]
اهلا وسهلا بكم ايه الاخبار عاملين ايه
انا اسمي رامي محمد كريتيف دايركتر
وهكلمكم النهارده عن طرق اسمه اكتفيت يور
كريتيف سايد دلوقتي انا عايز اسالكم سؤال
مين فينا هنا بيعتبر نفسه
اوكي طب ايه هي فائده الكريت في حياتنا
وفي سؤال مهم جدا او يمكن اهم سؤال فيهم
ايه اصلا معنى
خلينا ناخدهم واحده واحده الكريتيفيتي
بشكل مبسط جدا هي ان انا لو عندي بعض
العناصر قدامي على الترابيزه فانا ازاي
اوصلهم ببعض او اوجد رابطه تربطهم مع بعض
هي دي الكاريتات دي كل واحد فينا بيبقى له
طريقه معينه في ربط العناصر او ربط الحلول
او ربط السلوشنز او ربط المواضيع ببعضها
بتختلف عن الشخص الاخر علشان كده انت ممكن
من الكريتيفي توصل لحلول كتير جدا في
حياتك وهنشوف مع بعض الكريتيفتي دي
هتنفعنا ازاي سواء في شغلنا سواء في بيتنا
سواء في كمان في الكليه بتاعتنا او في
دراستنا وعلشان كده احنا دلوقتي هديكم مثل
بسيط جدا هيكون هتكلم عن الشغل بتاعي او
عن الكارير باس بتاعي وازاي الكريتيفتي
ساعدتني ان انا اوصل لحاجات كثيره جدا ما
كنتش اتخيلها انا وانا صغير كنت بحب الرسم
جدا وكنت بحب الاعلانات جدا وكنت بحب
الجرافيكس جدا وابتديت واحده واحده لغايه
ما دخلت كليه الفنون الجميله وبعدين كنت
بقى بتفوق وحاجات كده بس لما طلعت من
الكليه للسوق لقيت
او الحاجه اللي انا عارفها او اللي انا
اكتسبتها في الكليه مش بس هي الكفايه
علشان اقدر اكمل بيها حياتي كلها فلقيت ان
انا اه بعرف ارسم دي حاجه كويسه جدا اه
بعرف اعمل تصميمات واعرف اعمل اعلانات دي
حاجه كويسه جدا فلقيت ان انا محتاج حاجه
مهمه جدا عشان اقدر اختلف عن غيري او اقدر
الاقي حاجات غيري مش بسهوله يقدر يلاقيها
فافتكرت حاجه اسمها
الكريتيفيتستونز طيب ايه الاسم الغريب ده
طبعا كلنا عارفين مارفل صح
مارفل كان في حاجه مهمه جدا فيها اسمها
دول هم اللي جمعهم ثانوس الفالون بتاع
مارفل علشان خاطر طبعا طول السلسله عمال
يتعب ويروح كواكب ويروح قوالب مختلفه
علشان يجمع دول وكان عنده هدف نبيل جدا ان
هو يخلص على نص البشريه تمام بس طبعا احنا
مش هنعمل احنا لما نجمع الكريتيفتي ستونز
دول احنا مش هنعمل زيه ونخلص على الناس
ولا حاجه احنا كل اللي احنا هنعمله هنجمع
الكاراتيه ستونز عشان تنفعنا ان احنا نقدر
لما نسناب اورنجرز نلاقي حلول كتير جدا
جدا ما كناش متخيلين ان احنا لوحدنا كان
ممكن نوصل لها خلينا نتكلم دلوقتي عن
الكريتفتيستونز على طول اه اول حاجه في
الكليت ستونز هي البرين ستورمينج البرينس
ستورمينج ده عباره عن ايه عباره ان انت
بتعمل توك بينك وبين شخص او اثنين او
ثلاثه او ايفين جروب اكبر من كده بشويه
انت بتعرض عليهم المشكله او بتعرض عليهم
اي معين في موضوع ما وبتبتدي تسالهم عن
ارائهم وبتبتدي تسالهم عن اللي هم شايفين
منه الموضوع ده بتبتدي تاخد منهم الاجوبه
وبتبتدي تاخد منهم الحلول وبتبتدي تكتب
وراهم كل حاجه بيقولوها لان الحاجات دي
مهمه جدا البرانس تورمين دي ممكن تحصل في
الشغل ممكن تحصل في البيت ممكن تحصل في
الكليه ممكن تحصل وانت قاعد في الكافيه مع
اصحابك مش ملهاش اي يعني ملهاش طريقه
برفشنال معينه كل ما في الموضوع ان انت
بتعرض الموضوع بتاعك او بتعرض المشكله
بتاعتك علشان توصل لحاجات معينه انت ما
كنتش لوحدك هتوصل لها ودي رقم واحد رقم
اثنين المايند مابينج المايند مابينج ده
بمنتهى البساطه كانه سكيتشنج انت بتعمل
مثلا سكتش بتجيب اسم الموضوع وليكن انا
بتكلم مثلا عن الكارير بتاعي فهكتب في
النص الكارير بتاع الكارير بتاعي عباره عن
كذا هطلع منه
تايتلز او هطلع من من الكلمه دي
كلمات صغيره تانيه الكلمات دي كل كلمه
ممكن يكون مثلا حاجه انا عملت فطلعت كلمه
لها علاقه بالكارير عملت مثلا او عملت
مثلا مع حد فطلعت كلمه او طلع لي او طلع
لي مثلا فكره جديده هبتدي اكتبهم كلهم
حوالين الكارير ده بطلعها افصصها زي ما
بيقولوا الكلمات صغيره وكل كلمه تتفصص
لكلمات تانيه صغيره وفي الاخر ببتدي كونكت
كل الكلام الصغير الاخراني ده باول كلمه
انا كتبتها او التاريخ بتاعي وهوصل لحل
تاني خلينا نخش في ثالث حاجه حاجه اسمها
الاورال برزنتيشن او انا بسميها
كان في في الافلام الكرتون اللي احنا
بنتكلم بنتفرج عليها زمان واحنا صغيرين
حاجه اسمها البومه الحكيمه البومه الحكيمه
دي بتبقى شخصيه ملهاش اي لازمه في الحياه
غير ان هي قاعده على الشجره وكل اما حد
بيجيلها بيبقى عنده مشكله او متخانق مع
صاحبه او عنده مثلا ازمه في شغله بيقعد مع
البومه الحكيمه ويسالها يقول لها يا بومه
انا عندي مشكله واضعها كذا كذا كذا ومحتاج
ان انت تلاقي لها حل فالبومه كل اللي هي
بتعمله بتفضل تقول له همم
فيقول لها ايه ده انت عرفت الحل ده ازاي
ده انت فظيعه جدا انا مش ممكن كنت الاقي
الحل ده لوحدي بصراحه وهو في حقيقه الامر
انت فيه يعني معلومه علميه انت لما بتعمل
لو انت واقف لوحدك في الاوضه انت كل اللي
بتعمله ان انت بتمرر الكلام من مخك بيترتب
فبيطلع من بقك فبيرجع مترتب على مخك ثاني
فانت بترجع الكلام لمخك بس بطريقه منظمه
فلما بتنظم او بترتب افكارك ومخك بيسمعها
تاني بيبتدي مخك نفسه يلاقي حلول او يلاقي
زي ما بنقول برسبكتف مختلف هو ما كانش
شايفه في الاول
فالبرزنتيشن ده ممكن يتعمل لوحدك بس بلاش
تعملوه لوحدكم عشان ما حد يعني قدام الناس
عشان ما حدش يقول ان احنا اتجننينا ولا
حاجه وطبعا مش هنروح للبومه الحكيمه ناخد
رايها بس احنا ممكن نعمله في البيت مع
ماما مثلا او مع صاحبتي او ممكن مثلا مع
صاحبي او اعمله في الكافيه ممكن على فكره
الشخص اللي انت بتكلمه هو مش مطلوب منه ان
هو يرد عليك خالص هو كل اللي بيعمله ان هو
بس بيمثل دور البومه الحكيم اهو خلينا
ناخد بعد كده حاجه اسمها
كان في عالم اسمه روكي العالم ده اخترع
طريقه بسيطه جدا جدا جدا لحل المشكلات او
هي طبعا الطريقه دي بنستخدمها لحل المسائل
خلينا ناخد برده موضوع الكارير دلوقتي انا
لو جبت الكارير بتاعي واستخدمت الكابلين
كويسشنز دي اللي هي هاو وير واي واتش
الحاجات دي كلها هي لو انت حطيت اي كلمه
منهم او اي تساؤل منهم قبل الموضوع بتاعك
دفنت ليه هتلاقيه له حل يعني انت لو قلت
مثلا انا ليه هشتغل في الكارير ده طيب هل
انا بحب الكاريت ده ولا لا طب امتى ابتدي
اشتغل فيه
الهابي اكسيدنس
عباره عن ايه عباره عن انا بعمل ريس
دلوقتي وبدور على الحل وبكلم ناس وبتصل
بناس وبعمل مثلا مع ناس علشان اوصل للحلول
اللي انا محتاجها او الاجوبه اللي انا
محتاجها فبيطلع معي كده اكسده يعني حاجات
انا ما كنتش مخطط لها يعني انا ممكن بسال
مثلا الاسئله بتاعه الكابل دي وانا بسالها
لقيت حاجه اصلا ملهاش علاقه بالكابلين
دلوقتي بس انا عشان دماغي شغاله ابتدا مخي
يشتغل فطالع لي دلوقتي اكسدنت بس دي هابي
يعني لقيت اه ده ممكن يبقى حل فالحل ده
ابتدي ادونه مش اول حاجه تطلع في دماغي
يبقى هي دي الصح لازم ادون كل الحاجات دي
علشان في الاخر اقارن بينهم واشوف انهي
واحده اسلم حاجه
بعد كده اخر حاجه في الكريات حاجه اسمها
الاهامومنتس الاهامس دي عباره عن ايه
دلوقتي وانا بعمل يعني ايه
التساؤلات بتاعتي وبعمل بتاعتي بقى وعماله
اذاكر الموضوع وبعمل والكلام ده ممكن اوصل
لحلول ازاي وانا قاعد لقيتها تمام اهو
لقيتها دي انت ممكن يعني ممكن خمس ست مرات
تحصل لك في نفس المشروع يعني انت كل ما
تلاقي تستخدم واحده من الكريات ستونز دي
كل شويه هتلاقي حاجه اسمها اه لقيتها اها
لقيتها فانت كل اللي انت هتعمله ان انت
هتكتب الاهم ومن سي دي في ورقه وبعدين
هتبتدي تقارن بينهم وتشوف افضل حاجه لان
مش اول مره يجيلك اها مومنت يبقى هو ده
الحل احنا كل اللي احنا عايزينه ان
الكرياتيف سايد اللي جوانا اللي هو بقاله
كتير جدا نايم جوانا واحنا ممكن ما نكونش
تعرض لنا تعرضنا له كثير عايزين نعمل له
اكتيفيشن وعايزين نبتدي
اللي جوانا علشان يفيدنا لو انا عندي
موضوع صغير عندي مشروع كبير حد هيتجوز حد
هيسافر حد هيفتح شركه حد بيقرر يتعلم ايه
او يدرس ايه او يكمل ايه كل الحاجات دي لو
احنا بس جمعنا
واشتغلنا بها هنبقى زينا زي كل الناس اللي
احنا بنلجا لهم لما بيكون عندنا مشكله
الناس الحكيمه بيكو بعد كده انا لما عملت
الكريتستونس دول وابتديت اشتغل للبلاينس
سواء في مصر او مره او بره مصر الاعلانات
اللي انا عملتها كان شكلها عامل ازاي
ده واحد من الاعلانات اللي انا عملتهم كان
عن اسمده يعني سماد للخضار والفاكهه وكده
وده الحمد لله الاعلانات يعني انتشر
عالميا وناس كتير جدا قلدته وده اعلان
تاني برده اترشح لكذا جائزه كان برده
بيتكلم عن الفاكهه ان حد الانجريدنس
بتاعته يعني فهو بيستخدم
ده ثالث حاجه اللي هو ده كان اعلان عن ال
ال السكر يعني الناس اللي عندها مرض السكر
انا بقول لك السكر بياكلك انت كمان مش
يعني مش انت اللي بتاكله انا بس دلوقتي
ممكن نرجع تاني لنفس اللي انا سالته لكم
في الاول هل حد هنا شايف نفسه كريتيف
يرفع ايديه يعني اللي شايف نفسه في
اليوتيوب يرفع ايديه
طيب هايل جدا هايل جدا احنا دايما زي ما
احنا قلنا الفنانين اول ادباء او الكتاب
او الممثلين الناس دي ما اتولدتش عندها
الناس دي اتعلمت ازاي تبقى وتعلمه ازاي
يطلعوا الفنان اللي جواهم واتعلموا ان هو
ياكتيفيه اللي جواه علشان سواء يبدا يعني
يقدر يبدع في المجال الفني او يقدر يبدا
كمان في المجال الادبي يا رب ان شاء الله
كلنا نبقى كريات في فتره وجيزه وباذن الله
بالكريتيفت ستونز دول هتحققوا كل اللي
بتتمنوه شكرا جدا ليكم شكرا شكرا